-Welcome back
to "That's My Jam."
I'm here with Ariana Grande,
Blake Shelton,
Kelly Clarkson, John Legend.
They are facing off in the
wheel of impossible karaoke.
Kelly, why don't you
come up here?
Let's see. Spin the wheel,
see what you got here.
Thank you, buddy.
-Come on, Kelly.
[ Musical beeping ]
-Boopity boopity bop boo boo.
-Mixtape Medley.
Oh! It's a showdown.
-♪ Medley of
your favorite songs ♪
♪ Mixtape Medley Showdown ♪
-It's a showdown.
-Okay.
-Which means going against
Ariana right now.
It's a showdown.
-Oh!
Yes! Let's go, Ari.
Come on.
-Oh, get ready for this.
-You got this.
You got this.
-We're done for.
-Come on, buddy.
-Alright.
Come on, come on, come on.
-Alright, alright.
-Definitely not.
-Here's how
Mixtape Medley Showdown works.
I'm gonna spin the wheel,
and you're gonna get the title
of a mixtape.
Then you're gonna have to
go back and forth
singing a medley of those songs.
Let's see what you get.
-Let's go, Ari! Let's go!
-Kelly Clarkson!
-Yes!
[ Musical beeping ]
-Is everything okay?
-Pop divas.
-Shocking, shocking.
-Alright, that means that
the band will play a medley
of some all-time
classic diva tracks.
So follow along the lyrics
as they pop up in front of you.
Here we go.
Band, whenever you're ready.
-Let's go, ladies.
-I'm nervous.
-Oh, my God, oh, my God.
-Yeah!
Oh, my God. Okay.
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪ Oops, I did it again ♪
♪ I played with your heart ♪
♪ Got lost in the game ♪
♪ Oh, baby, baby ♪
-Yes.
-♪ Any man of mine ♪
♪ Better walk the line ♪
♪ He better show me a teasin',
squeezin' ♪
♪ Pleasin' kind of time ♪
-♪ Do you believe
in life after love? ♪
-♪ After love,
after love, after love ♪
-♪ I can feel something
inside me say ♪
♪ I really don't think
you're strong enough, no ♪
-♪ It's not fair to deny me ♪
♪ Of the cross I bear ♪
♪ That you gave to me ♪
♪ You, you, you oughta know ♪
♪ Un-break my heart ♪
♪ Say you'll love me again ♪
♪ Undo this hurt
that you caused ♪
♪ When you walked out the door ♪
♪ And walked out of my life ♪
-♪ Baby, baby ♪
♪ He treats you like this ♪
♪ And you treat me like that ♪
♪ This was all long ago ♪
♪ But it's all
coming back to me now ♪
♪ It's all coming back ♪
It's coming back to you, Jimmy.
It's coming back to us.
-♪ And I-I-I-I-I ♪
♪ Will always love you ♪
♪ I will always ♪
♪ Love yo-u-u-u-u-u ♪
♪ Lo-o-o-o-o-ve ♪
-♪ Yo-u-u-u-u-u-u ♪
-Yes!
-Come on, now.
That was unbelievable.
This was amazing.
Oh, my God.
Wow!
That was --
Never seen something like that.
Unbelievable.
-Oh, my God.
-Wow.
-Whoo!
-How? How?
-Fantastic.
-We have to go back
to our judge, the Doombox.
It's time to decide,
was it John and Kelly
or was it Blake and Ariana?
-Ari and Blake
really made this place shake.
And Kelly and John definitely
ran it like a marathon.
So this is the hardest decision
I've ever had to make.
Jam band, may I have
a drum roll please?
[ Drum roll ]
-This is the craziest day
of my life.
-The winner is...
...Kelly Clarkson
and John Legend.
-Yes! Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You killed it.
You deserve it.